for a while the Disney 2d animation
studio was shut down this is because the
last few movies that were made were not
huge financial successes half of them
were even critical successes so after a
long time away Disney decide to finally
return to its fruits go back to the
fairy tales go back to the happily ever
afters go back to the magical stuff this
is where the princess and the frog comes
in let me tell you I was excited to see
an animated 2d Disney film on the big
screen again and not just a satire one I
mean a real one and personally in my
opinion it didn't disappoint okay story
you got a young woman named Tiana she
has a dream of opening her own
restaurant after her father passes away
I guess some Disney traditions never do
truly die she works her butt off to save
as much money as she can well that's
going on a prince from a faraway land a
prince naveen comes into town his
parents cut off his finances because
he's too much of a party animal but then
he comes across the shadow man he tricks
not being into having him agreed to have
his soul be put into a frog while his
assistant would take on the appearance
of the prince and also work for the
shadow man at a costume party Naveen
confuses Tiana for a princess and asks
her to kiss him she agrees hoping des
riches will help keep her restaurant
open but seeing how she wasn't a true
princess she gets turned into a frog -
and the rest of the movie is them trying
to figure out how to lift the curse and
how to stop the evil Shadow Man let's
look at our characters Tiana is probably
the best female lead since Belle she's a
fast thinker she's positive and she's a
workaholic God never thought you see
that in the Disney princess would you
the prince is also a lot of fun he's
full of himself but he's also got a lot
of innocence to him
Tiana's best friend is hilarious
I haven't seen a Disney character this
funny in a long time Prince Naveen
Naveen ovule Dona is coming to Marlon
did Big Daddy yeah every second she is
on screen she just cracks me up a
villain is also a lot of fun the fact
that he's into voodoo allows for a lot
of creative visuals and a lot of great
possibilities and they take advantage of
them all the other ends of the side
characters are also very memorable you
got alligator who wants to be a musician
a redneck Firefly who thinks he's in
love with a star in the sky
which doctor who always has the answer
to every question so okay this film
sounds about as good as the classic
traditional great Disney movies what
could possibly go wrong with it well
there's only one problem with the movie
and sadly it's kind of a big one the
story it's not that it's bad it's just a
little too complicated I mean okay I
told you the basics but I didn't tell
you about the fact that what the Shadow
Man has a deal with the underworld so
that he can take control of the town but
in order to take control the town he has
to have the guy who looks like the
Prince marry the daughter of the mayor
of the town but in order to do that they
constantly need the blood of the Frog
Prince to constantly give to that guy or
else his disguise will fade away but it
turns out the prince has to be kissed by
the daughter of the mayor because the
mayor always appoints himself the king
of the parade which technically makes
her a princess but that has to be done
before midnight on a certain day but on
top of that you also have to have the
two main characters fall in love with
each other while they're discovering how
to fix their own faults as well as each
others oh and I mentioned that there's
also a totally unnecessary death and a
totally goofy silly funeral scene
that'll either make you laugh or cry or
both oh my god it's too much I always
said that this should have been called
loophole the movie because that's what
it always seems like every second
they're trying to look for a new
loophole to get around something now is
it a major problem
I guess not because you're constantly
guessing what's gonna happen but one of
the charms of movies like The Little
Mermaid Beauty and the Beast Aladdin and
so forth is that the stories were always
very flowing they knew exactly how much
to give to the characters and exactly
how much to give to the details this
movie has way too many details going on
but like I said it's not that bad it's
just not as good as the other Disney
flicks had to put together yes the songs
are Randy Newman songs and to be fair
two of them are pretty good friends on
the other side is a great villain song
and almost there actually has a very
memorable nice beat to it the others
I don't remember and again I guess that
is a problem with the movie but again to
the movies credit it does take place New
Orleans and at least the musical style
does match even it's not all memorable I
guess before I wrap up I should talk
about some of the controversy that's
around in this movie of course Tiana was
the first Black Prince
and there was a lot of talk about the
fact that originally she was supposed to
be a chambermaid they changed it and
made her a waitress but that caused a
lot uproar - oh it's changing history oh
it's changing the way things were back
then well you know what there's a
talking frog I think we'll live
yeah it's changing things but you know
what we're always gonna have reminders
of how things really work this is a
fairy tale let the kids have their fairy
tale on top of that there's also
controversy about why the film didn't do
as well as Disney was hoping now it
didn't Bob let me clarify that but it
wasn't the gigantic hit they were hoping
for was it racism was the world just not
ready for a black princess yet I guess
it could be but I have my own theory I
think it is the prejudice but it's not
against black people
it's against hand-drawn films it's been
a while since one has been marketed to
both adults and kids and let's be honest
this is still a family picture and the
majority of family pictures coming out
nowadays are either live-action or 3d
personally I think a lot of adults still
see hand-drawn films as kids stuff now
it could give people in the seats if it
was really doing something new like The
Little Mermaid or just did a spectacular
Lea like Beauty and the Beast and to be
fair even though I like this film it
really didn't it updated the fairy tale
very nicely and very cleverly but the
problems with the story do hold it back
from being anything spectacular and like
I said before only a few of the Randy
Newman songs are memorable there's no be
our guest in there so that's my theory
but to be honest it still made money I'd
be more concerned if nobody saw it but
you know what people did was it a ton of
them no but at the same time a lot of
the past Disney 2d anime films didn't
have a ton of people looking at them and
nobody scream racism at that but I don't
know all the people in the world so it's
anybody's guess it's just a theory
I'm the hole though I really enjoyed
this one I felt just like I was seeing
little mermaid or Beauty and the Beast
again it was great to see it on the big
screen it was great to see these
characters and I had a lot of fun
watching it the animations great the
colors are great the characters are
great I enjoyed watching it and I know
I'll be seeing it a few more times in
the future
you